it's been a year since several powerful
earthquakes struck turkey a and Syria
killing at least 59,000 people in
leaving hundreds of thousands homeless
to Mark the anniversary thousands of
people have marched in the Turkish
province of hat the worst hit region
demonstrators chanted we won't forgive
we won't forget they say the government
did not act quickly enough in the
immediate aftermath of the disaster some
protesters fought with police when they
tried to close a road
well the earthquakes caused widespread
destruction across a vast area on
February the 6th 2023 just after 4 a.m.
the magnitude 7.7 Quake struck near the
southern Turkish province of karaman
marash less than 20 minutes later a
magnitude 6.5 Tremor hit near
gazan then that afternoon a third quake
hit karaman marash again this time in
the north of the province the the
earthquakes affected an area of
120,000 Square kmers including parts of
Northern Syria 59,000 people were killed
and more than
107,000
injured 14 million people in Turkey a
and Syria were
affected okay let's bring in bit Tazia
from akut which is a volunteer
organization involved in search and
rescue operations here's the groups Le
on officer to the UN and joins us from
Birmingham in the United Kingdom thank
you so much for your time you were
involved in the search and rescue in the
aftermath of the earthquake a year ago
what do you remember of your
experience hi Meen um I just remember
that it was uh quite overwhelming we're
all people uh domestic responders from
across turkey and of course from around
the world we're all trained for these
situations but in terms of U Disaster
Response and rescue recovery however the
uh what we remember is of course the
extreme temperatures that were very very
below freezing and the vast geography
across which their the damage had spread
and at at first it was really
overwhelming to take in how widespread
the damage was and uh across 10
provinces like you said in your report
and um that all you remember in terms of
trying to comprehend how wide spread the
damage once and how challenging is it uh
in your experience to rebuild often
earthquake of this kind of magnitude I
mean we we heard from the Turkish
president in the aftermath promising to
rebuild more than 300,000 homes by now
but we've been hearing in our reporting
many survivors still living in shipping
containers and
Tents uh that may be so um I can't speak
to uh the Govern the implementation of
government's policies but the when we
walk around the area whether it be Kai
or Gant it's usually a mixture of
progress you will see uh parts of the
cities that are completely flattened
because the buildings have been uh
removed and the recovery efforts have
been completed you'll see um camps have
been set up by the National Emergency
Management Authority aat and you'll
still see areas that um that are still
waiting to be torn down so it's a
because of such a vast geography uh it's
um government government may have made
promises but there is you know there is
the realities is on the ground and I
can't speak to um uh the progress of how
or how far they're into their into their
rebuilding of buildings in terms of in
terms of housing new people okay B stay
with us because I'm just going to turn
to our correspondent now she is uh in
isander in Turkey C kolu uh which is not
too far from hassai which is one of the
areas most impacted by the earthquake CM
uh you've been talking to people we saw
your package how are people there coping
a year
on
uh well yes this area is also affected
by the earthquake as you said and uh
many people hundreds of thousands of
people are still living in the container
uh cities as you have also mentioned but
of course the damage was so big and we
are talking about 11 cities nearly 13
million people who were living in those
areas and nearly three million people
have been pushed out from the cities but
of course uh what we have seen this time
uh on the first
year after the earthquake that people
are trying to uh revive their cities
people are trying to survive and they
are more hopeful than uh before but of
course there are very sad stories there
are very dramatic stories but uh I would
like to focus on a positive story today
in escandon we are uh at a container
City this is a PRI uh this is uh founded
by a private company of course uh run by
the government's uh disaster management
agency and right behind me you will see
a big kitchen uh this kitchen is called
soul to Soul Kitchen it's mainly
volunteers who have established this uh
it's not a foundation but this
initiative let me say since the first
days of the earthquake so far nearly
4,000 volunteers have worked in these uh
in this kitchen and they have been
providing food to the earthquake
survivors and people who have been
affected uh in the earthquake areas
nearby cities uh since the very first
day and
today the they are cooking uh big
portions of food uh you are seeing uh
big uh pans outside of course they they
have cooked inside but today they have
extra portions to cook because today is
also a special day in Islam and many
people are fasting today that's why the
food that is being cooked today will be
delivered to uh many uh container cities
and camps uh nearby and uh they will be
packed they will be sent H for dinner
for if they to uh uh to help people
break their fast H and right now today
there are 120 volunteers who are working
cooking delivering packing and uh in an
hour or so we will see people uh the
camp residents and uh some uh local
officials arriving here and joining Mass
prayer they will be praying inside this
kitchen for the victims uh of the
earthquake uh that's why people are very
excited and they are very happy to be a
part of uh this good work good will
because we have seen so many sad stories
and people need hope here M okay thank
you for that CM kolu uh in iseran uh the
port city in Turkey let's return back to
Billy Taz tazir from akut which is a
volunteer organization involved in in
search and rescue after uh disasters
like this uh a positive story there from
iskenderun um but long term I mean let's
talk about a bit more about the
challenges involved in recovering from
an earthquake like this I mean what
about the mental scars for example
people went through something
unimaginable uh how important is it that
uh that that there is that support
available to to deal with the mental uh
weight if at
all uh it's it's actually quite
important because I mean we just like we
heard in the report there the um no
matter how devastating the uh the
earthquake and the its aftermath was
what's what's also remarkable was that
this whole event brought out the best of
people uh and uh it and that is a very
important emotion and motivation to hold
on to during the recovery efforts
because no government or no organization
is going to get it right people do what
they can in the most dire circumstances
um and it is just uh and it's very
important that these positive stories
come out and to encourage others to uh
be able to see that we can also do this
and Recovery is possible no matter how
long or short it might last uh because
uh on the on the back of Devastation on
the back of s such of these these um
these devastating stories that we've
heard last year it brought out the best
of humanitarian action uh and and
response and and this is one of them uh
and it it shows us uh what is possible
and encourages uh not only the the the
victims but also the authorities to uh
build and recover uh as best as they can
what would you say are the biggest
Lessons Learned From This
earthquake well I would say that um
first of all we must accept the fact
that uh there are regions in country
like turkey uh that and the reality of
living near f lines and these fault
lines are not going to go away countries
are not going to get up and move so we
must learn to live and prepare uh to for
for the prer earthquake that's coming we
know for sure that whether it be
tomorrow or the next 20 30 years there
will be other earthquakes hitting this
Temple for example uh and so the
buildings must be tested people must
prepare their houses and even you know
buildings that are built but old
standard years or decades ago must be
rebuilt uh to withstand uh these sorts
of earthquakes we have stories such as
in in in Japan where we have very
earthquakes at very high in the rich
richer scale but very minimal uh uh
damage to or loss of human life so it is
possible to prepare um and we must
accept this reality and and basically
prepare the cities that we live in for
what we know is going to happen for sure
and organizations like yourselves uh are
so important uh when it comes to dealing
with disasters like this and dealing
with the aftermath in terms of the
amount of Aid being provided to Turkey a
uh both domestically and internationally
what is your understanding of uh what is
available whether there's been enough
provided if more is
needed it this is kind of thisit a
little bit of a paradox humanitarian
response because uh immediately after
the event happened we were overwhelmed
by the uh the amount of Aid that was
pouring in domestically in interally to
the region in so far that we cannot able
to we're not able to process them
properly uh and distribute them timely
sometimes because it was so much um now
it's more on the hands of international
organizations and that of the government
to accept this Aid and distribute it
properly and and this brings its own
challenges because now um although the
uh there are victims in the area that
are still trying to recover from the
event but it's not as um let's say
high-profile anymore uh that's in the
perception of the uh of the audiences uh
because it's happened a year ago so the
uh the aid has is ongoing but of course
not at the level that uh is uh is
happening or has happened in the
immediate aftermath of the earthquake
okay I appreciate your time belet tazir
from akut a volunteer organization
involved in search and rescue operations
speaking to us there from Birmingham in
the United
Kingdom